the Great Mouse Detective this is
actually one of the first Disney films I
ever saw in feelers and when you're a
little kid watching the magic of Disney
on the big screen this is exactly what
you want to open up with
mommy that scary as farc
well after that the movie is actually
much more tape at least not quite as
creepy the movie is about a little girl
trying to get her father back she comes
across a mouse named Dawson and they
both come across a mouse named basil of
Baker Street
who's the rodent equivalent of Sherlock
Holmes in fact he actually lives in
Sherlock Holmes house they're off to not
only find the little girl's father but
also stop an evil villain named Ratigan
played by Vincent Price his plan is to
have her father make a robotic Queen so
that he can replace her at some sort of
ceremony where the robotic Queen would
then name him the ruler of the land no
no it's for kids mice are running around
they can talk you can get away with this
shit I guess and anyway that's not the
focus of the movie the focus of the
movie is actually what it should be the
hero and the villain the hero in this
movie is great he's this egotistical but
still very likable character he's
energized he's kooky he's tenacious he's
a jerk sometimes but he's got a good
heart it's all that great stuff you love
in a hero and on top of that he's smart
as hell it's actually one of those few
Disney films where you admire how
intelligent the main character is I mean
from beginning to end you actually want
to be smarter watching him and then of
course there's the villain
voiced by Vincent Price what more do I
have to say it's Vincent Price and he is
loving every minute of it he's
egotistical he's selfish he sings he
prances around he giggles he just enjoys
being nasty so much that it's hard not
to enjoy it along with them the two play
off each other brilliantly it's just
these two gigantic brilliant egos
working off of one another I usually
find them with a celebrity voice even
the really good ones you can often sort
of feel them in the recording booth like
yeah they're acting but you know they're
acting you can see them saying their
lines into the microphone with Vincent
Price I never got that he's just right
there in the role it's Ratigan watch
this movie again and tell me if you can
really
disconnect the recording of Vincent
Price with the animation of the
character they're just flawless oh by
the way Bassam I just love your disguise
one would hardly recognize him they meld
together perfectly well on the subject
of the animation that's pretty good too
I think this is actually the first time
they started using computer graphics in
an animated and speaking of that it
makes for a great climax there's a giant
fight scene in the clock tower and it's
among one of Disney's best the angles
are great the music builds the pacing is
wonderful and we see Ratigan finally
show his true colors in fact it gets
pretty violent I mean there's no blood
or anything but there might as well be
the sound effects and everything really
make it look like it hurts but hey when
you're a little kid that just sucked you
in even more the Great Mouse Detective
is really smart really delightful and
really fun it is sort of your typical
little mouse adventure where they just
look at the big world and sort of create
their own little world and you laugh and
giggle at it but like I said what sets
it apart from the other ones is the main
character and the main villain there's
just a ton of fun to watch I think it's
one that often sneaks under the radar
for most Disney fans but it's definitely
worth checking out find it on DVD and
discover for yourself
you